it did have the biggest red eyes there's
a six-foot bird and massive winnings and
I asked her how big the wingspan was she
said about 10 to 12 feet is Point
Pleasant haunted yes very much
[Music]
I'm here in Point Pleasant West Virginia
the little Appalachian town with a big
monster history it's home to one of
America's most notorious legends Mothman
described as a humanoid creature with
massive wings and glowing red eyes this
man with wings was first spotted in this
area in the 1960s and has been a fixture
of life in Point Pleasant ever since
the monster is a perfect example of
iconic modern American folklore there's
even a Mothman statue in the middle of
downtown hi it speaks to the idea that
this really is modern folklore it came
from this towns like we're staking this
spot in this part of the world as
Mothman so they're really uniting
Mothman and Point Pleasant and West
Virginia on December 15th 1967 this
paranormal activity culminated in a very
real tragedy the collapse of Silver
Bridge some claims Mothman was the cause
of the accident others say he was
actually meant to forewarn the town of
the catastrophe
but how do you explain the Mothman
phenomenon was it an elaborate hoax or
did people simply mistake something real
for an imaginary creature or maybe it
was something truly so bizarre that it
just can't be easily explained
I'm dr. Emily Zarqa and this is monstrum
on November 12 1966 in Clendenin West
Virginia five grave diggers claimed to
have seen what they described as a man
with wings gliding over their heads I
witness Kenneth Duncan later said the
beam was gliding through the trees and
was in sight for about a minute but it
was here where Mothman became a legend
I'm at the spot of what is widely
believed to be the earliest officially
reported Mothman sighting
what used to be the West Virginia
ordnance works munitions plant better
known as the TNT area on November 15
1966 two young married couples Roger and
Linda Scarberry and Steve and Mary Malec
were driving around the TNT area when
they reportedly spotted what looked like
a man with large wings standing in the
middle of the road Steve described the
creature as being six or seven feet tall
with a ten-foot wingspan and red eyes
about two inches in diameter and six
inches apart Linda claims she couldn't
see a head or arms but also saw glowing
red eyes when the car headlights hit the
figure who seemed to shy away from the
light frightened they quickly sped away
from the figure but shortly after while
traveling along route 62 they spotted it
again this time it followed them
they claimed they couldn't shake the
creature even when the car reached
speeds as fast as a hundred mile
this is Denny Bellamy the Mason County
Visitors Bureau executive director Denny
has lived in the Point Pleasant Mason
County area for over 60 years I was I
was in third grade my neighbors saw it
said there's a large there's a six-foot
bird with big red eyes and massive wings
chasing cars in the tanti and in fact it
kept up with Roger scar Barry's 57 Chevy
right on this road this road as you can
see it's like a drag strip and that's
what Roger Scarberry was doing out here
was drag racing there were scratch marks
on the ceiling and I was car and he was
upset and he was scared shaken by the
experience the group drove straight to
the sheriff's office to file a report
around 2:00 a.m. that morning officers
immediately set out to investigate but
by the time they arrived at the TNT site
no evidence of the creature could be
found I'm here at the Point Pleasant
Public Library doing some research
looking through their archive there's a
lot of stuff here I'm super excited to
explore this is a copy of the original
Point Pleasant register of the first
Mothman sighting Wednesday November 16th
so I would have in the morning after
couple sees man-sized bird creature
something
well there's drawings scars Barry
eyewitness sketch of Mothman verified by
others one of the original eyewitnesses
both were slightly pale and tired from
lack of sleep during the night following
their harrowing experience I had it seen
it while by myself I wouldn't have said
anything but there were four of us who
saw it they speculated that the thing
was living in the vacant power plant
possibly one of the huge boilers there
are pigeons and all the other buildings
but not in that one I love finding new
info this was a top-secret government
facility
they made all the explosives from the
atomic bomb it employed all the people
from the town you would come to work
here onto a bus that all the windows
were blacked out of so you couldn't see
anything in the facility and they drove
you right to where you were working did
your job you got back on the bus and
they never saw anything and the day we
dropped the bomb on her rush mode they
closed the facility was that they were
done we're going to go look at the
bunkers that give the TNT area its name
it's where they stored the explosives
the tea tea and nitroglycerin it's
creepy first start bringing people out
here there were still rusted
hands of gunpowder so here's definitely
some Mothman graffiti I mean we have the
humanoid structure we have the wings the
big you see two large eyes
I grew up in forests but there's
something about the abandoned building
and the legends and the real history
that there's a spooky vibe
I mean it's honestly really really
creepy we're walking into one of the
buildings that used to be part of the
TNT site so we're gonna go in we have no
idea what's inside it's pitch black
let's see what happens okay I don't know
how far back it goes look at dark and I
don't know what it was used for and
there's stuff everywhere
definitely looks like it could be
haunted especially about the workers
used to be here and you never know who
would I just kick something okay no more
creeped out not have been in that
building over the following three days
after the November 15th sighting at
least eight more people reported similar
creatures my brothers and we don't look
but there's something there beside the
car if I'd roll my window down I just
could've touched it
and then it jumped on the hood and just
sit there and just squatted kind of look
this but it did have the biggest red
eyes and it run right past the car and
it jumped up in there and just opened up
the biggest pretty set of bird wings
because you could see the feathers and
everything just opened up and just went
off in the night like that for one year
starting in November 1966 over a hundred
eye witnesses reported accounts of the
Mothman in this area almost all agreed
on the same points the monster was as
large as larger than a big man it had
wings but no feathers and took off into
the air straight like a helicopter
gliding through the sky its face was
indistinguishable besides two large
glowing red eyes
the town's population was so intrigued
by the creature that hundreds of local
residents some armed went hunting for
the winged figure there was police
officer directing traffic there was so
much newspapers are often the first
indicators of an emerging legend they
help rumors become lore as more
variations are published and told to the
public Mothman was no exception he even
received his famous title from an
anonymous Ohio newspaper copy editor who
likely gave the mysterious bird the name
Mothman after the famous comic book
character Batman who is the subject of a
popular TV show at the time later that
month the Beckley Herald Dispatch
renamed the Mothman as the Mason bird
monster but that didn't quite stick
where the Mothman eyewitnesses in the
1960s really seeing a monster
some people certainly saw something in
the night sky the sheer number of
sightings might be an example of the
psychological and social phenomenon
known as mass hysteria the textbook
definition of mass hysteria says it is a
form of mass contagion in which an
irrational belief or behavior grips a
group or community the size of a small
town link Point Pleasant offered a
unique social environment residents
either had a Mothman story themselves or
knew someone who did which allowed the
story to circulate in a relatively
closed Internet work that could bolster
the belief in the creature what is
undoubtedly very real as the event that
stopped the Mothman sightings of the
1960s on December 15 1967 exactly 13
months after the first reported sighting
of Mothman an estimated 31 cars and
trucks plunged into the Ohio River after
the bridge connecting Ohio and West
Virginia collapsed 64 people went into
the water 46 of them died
it officially entered the mothman that's
what ended the story yeah that was that
when the bridge failed no one want to
hear about the Mothman anymore
it was Altima Lee discovered that a
single eye bar 55 feet long fractured
causing the pin holding it in place
to become loose and the tragic chain of
events to follow survivors and witnesses
recall that the bridge shook violently
before it collapsed some even say they
saw Mothman on the bridge days before
this is really where the myth of the
Mothman as a harbinger of death started
was he a warning to the townspeople or a
curse being bringing destruction with
him some people speculated that Mothman
and the bridge collapse had something to
do with a rumored legend known as the
curse of cornstalk a Shawnee leader of
the outlet indigenous people chief
cornstalk and his men fought in the
Battle of Point Pleasant against
colonial troops in 1774 local legend in
Point Pleasant said that with his dying
breath cornstalk cursed the town for 200
years
some people even speculated that the
Mothman was sent by cornstalk himself
from beyond the grave
but in 2006 it was revealed that the
rumored curse of cornstalk was nothing
more than a myth a rediscovered
historical pageant play was found in an
old grade school in Point Pleasant that
includes corn stalks curse most likely
the playwright added it in to give the
performance a little more drama and the
energies of its people paralyzed by the
stain of our blood so saying he fell
dead by the side of the Sun there's the
curse maybe the Mothman sightings can be
explained by something from the natural
world it was proposed early on that the
Mothman was actually a sandhill crane
when a West Virginia University
professor told the press in an article
published December 1st 1966 quote I
definitely believe that's what these
people are seeing this is the sandhill
crane dr. Robert Smith of the West
Virginia University biology department
said the description fits that of a
sandhill crane sandhill cranes have an
average wingspan of around 6.5 feet and
are about 3 to 4 feet tall they also
happen to have
red patches around their eyes but dr. Z
you may be wondering do sandhill cranes
ever make it to West Virginia the answer
is yes because I am a crazy bird person
and this Mothman thing was driving me
insane
I contacted the Cornell Lab of
Ornithology for sandhill crane data from
the 1960s while they couldn't give me
anything from that time period I did
find that sightings of sandhill cranes
happened today at least 28 of them have
been spotted in West Virginia between
January 2017 and August 2019 sometimes
in large groups Brendon Knight the
sister-in-law of one of the November 15
witnesses said quote we all thought it
was a mutant sandhill crane because of
the toxins in the swamp maybe Brenda was
onto something she wasn't the only one
to think that illegally dumped chemicals
had caused animal mutations the
munitions plant that gave the TNT area
its name was built during World War two
to produce and store explosives from
1942 to 1945 after the war much of the
land was given to the Department of
Natural Resources it became a wildlife
reserve in 1966 and is now called the
McClintock Wildlife Management Area the
mutation theory might have a little more
validity to it than some of the other
explanations in 1981 a red water seep
was discovered in the area which led to
the realization that contamination had
occurred the red water is a result of a
cold water and select mixture used to
rinse the TNT according to the US Army
Corps of Engineers the red water was
discharged directly to the Ohio River
through a pipe located about one foot
offshore after becoming part of the
national priority list in 1983 cleanup
became the focus and ground water
extraction was completed in 1997 so how
could you explain mothman's infamous
glowing red eyes another type of bird
was quickly thrown out as a possible
explanation to the humanoid flying
creature one known for its silent
nocturnal flights owls it's always owls
birds eyes appear Brad when a bright
light is shined at them because of the
vascular membrane that shows through the
pigment layer of the retina an effect
referred to as eye
one owl is known for its very dramatic
eye shine
the barred owl is a large species with
the rounded head common throughout the
southeast that prefers to roost in old
trees in open forests extra blood
vessels around their eyes make them glow
more red than other species officials at
the McClintock Wildlife Management Area
told the Audubon Society who also looked
at Al's as an explanation for Mothman
that the area has a healthy population
of the species some people in Point
Pleasant argue that Mothman was really
just a lost weather balloon or even an
elaborate hoax a local rumor exists
alongside Mothman himself what about a
local teenage prankster who found it fun
to jump out at cars driving at night in
the TNT area while wearing a Halloween
costume hoaxes like these could have
happened on more than one occasion but
that doesn't really explain the Mothman
phenomenon you're probably wondering how
we've gotten this far without mentioning
the Mothman Prophecies written by John
keel the book and its 2002 film
adaptation are the most important texts
for how the legend took root outside of
Point Pleasant Hill was a journalist and
paranormal investigator who went to
Point Pleasant in December 1966 to
explore the Mothman and other
supernatural sightings in the area he
interviewed a lot of the original
witnesses and even claimed to have
experience with what he calls ultra
terrestrials I read the whole thing and
it's a doozy honestly the book seems
more concerned about UFOs and men in
black than Mothman regardless of how
factual the Mothman Prophecies is or not
the 1975 book and the movie did have one
indisputable result they made Mothman
globally recognized and turned the town
of Point Pleasant into a tourist
destination quite frankly I mean there's
only one Mothman and there's only one
Point Pleasant people were really
interested in that although I wasn't and
actually the town wasn't the town didn't
believe it although there were there
kept on being sightings the newspaper
kept writing about it but it was mostly
too tongue-in-cheek it was all that but
frankly still is today for most
one time someone said I'd like we'd like
to talk to some people that don't
believe in the Mothman I said pick any
one on Main Street one year after the
movie came out they erected a statue of
him on Main Street in 2003 we're
dedicating the statue and and we're all
kind of the mayor and everyone's kind of
like jeez you know the mayor has to
speak at the dedication I go over to see
what's going on I have to come back I
said you probably ought to put a suit in
Taiwan he said what's going on I said
CBS is here
TBS Sunday morning bill geist is out
there that's willie geist father and
that's that's how it started when bill
guy showed up i became a monk man
believers and in 2005 a whole Mothman
museum opened up created by jeff
walmsley Point Pleasant resident and
local Mothman expert it sees thousands
of visitors a year a lot of the movie
props that we have here in the museum
were donated and that was kind of like
the catalyst to get the museum going the
Mothman festival was started back in
2002 but it's a big boon to the tourism
here I mean with the festival in the
museum people have embraced it you know
you still have skeptics which is fun I
mean you know I'm not out to convince
anybody of anything I mean everything in
the museum is for people to decide for
themselves
they weren't sure that they really
wanted the Mothman in our town and but
the Mothman festival grew every year we
had to they were all coming we had no
choice tourism has grown and grown and
our entire state is embraced it now that
is in one weekend here the entire town
will tell you anything you want to know
about the plan and we just enjoy looking
at everybody it's entertaining for us
how much money is made on average now at
least probably two million flows down on
Main Street on that weekend which is
probably more than the rest of year you
know we attract 10 to 12 thousand people
so the town's population doubles you
know the local people they're used to it
I mean they're used to the attention and
everything and don't get me wrong Point
Pleasant has a lot to offer rather than
just Mothman you know Native American
history riverboat history Farm Museum
River Museum all that kind of stuff
to me I think you know the Mothman story
is just a nice way to get people
attention they come here and they like
oh you know we got the flood wall murals
you know we got the river museum there's
I don't see anything negative about it
you know with the help of the Internet
Mothman has become a global phenomenon
online rumors circulate frequently some
claiming that he was spotted before the
Chernobyl disaster and even in the smoke
of the towers at 9/11 most recently the
largest number of Mothman sightings in
one area occurred in Chicago in 2017
there were more than 20 reports of a
winged humanoid in Chicago from April to
July of that year whether you believe in
him or not
Mothman has become a cultural touchstone
a monster myth that inspires both fear
and fascination legends only truly take
root when they become a subject of
conflicting opinions they are born in
stories told and retold with countless
contradictions
and disputes Mothman is no different
he's been demonized and deified in
almost equal measure
Mothman shows us how a local phenomenon
can become a global sensation people
identify with Mothman
he's a rumor and an outcast a monster
who was ultimately embraced by the small
town that once feared him whether the
people of Point Pleasant liked it or not
Mothman is now part of their town's
identity it can even be argued that the
people of Point Pleasant embraced the
creature because it made their little
part of the world visible to a lot more
people like other small towns a portion
of the town's economic survival depends
on its ability to attract outsiders it
does feel like a ruin and I always think
that ruins carry some kind of energy
that allows them to attract myths like
this I'm not surprised being here now
that there were so many Mothman
sightings I'm actually not I don't know
I think it's probably a bird some kind
of giant bird maybe mutated maybe just
abnormally large and freakish but
there's something and the way this
forest is so creepy there's definitely a
way that imagination could have run wild
a hundred percent personal opinion I
have also been in a lot of creepy
forests and
this one tastes the cake I don't know
five is monster this is where I hang out
a legend survives when it is able to
adapt to the current cultural moment the
Mothman has done this astonishingly well
he's gone from mysterious humanoid to
prophetic demon guardian angel to old
for terrestrial scary monster to cute
cryptid and everything in between
interestingly no witness has ever
reported this creature harmed a human
maybe he really is just your friendly
neighborhood mock Mothman is about
number five on the list of things I
don't want to run into out here snakes I
do not like snakes
[Music]